je savais qu'ils avaient été là
auparavant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et qu'ils allaient revenir
je crois qu'ils ont des chiottes dans
cette décharge
au mauvais endroit mon corps j'ai vu
joli mais ça ne va pas tarder
elle dégage est allé voir ailleurs je
suis
[Musique]
car il n'allait jamais une foire si tu
regardes et à ma connaissance non
seulement deux longueurs
tu es là nous sommes littéralement en
train d'assister au débarquement d'une
civilisation extraterrestre
derrière moi
des faits comme aura
durant ces six dernières années ils ont
opéré des tests dans le but de se
préparer pour ce soir
rien dit à personne j'en ai parlé à tout
le monde ces [ __ ] mon au prix
pourquoi ne vous êtes juste au mauvais
endroit au mauvais moment
j'imagine qu'en langage djeuns vous
diriez qu'il bouche de l'espèce humaine
une autre mise à jour phénoménal